I want to look to Britain's future a
little bit longer than just the next few
weeks or months visiting one of my
primary schools at the beginning of last
week and I asked the head teacher what
it was that his Latin motto meant and
rather embarrassingly he didn't know and
and so I checked it out it was munis
Priory I don't know how many Latin
scholars there are here and I could know
but its duty before rights now yesterday
writing in The Observer
David Isaac the chair of the equality
and Human Rights Commission said that
the challenge is to ensure we don't end
up in the siloed world where everybody
is sensitive about their own individual
interests and less empathetic about how
other people are treated and what he's
identified I think as the key issue is
how we move beyond the I to the we how
do we think of ourselves as citizens who
are not just focused on what works for
me and my own narrow group so the
question what is Britain's future the
question has to answers a future based
on I or a future based on we a future
based on my rights or a future based on
my duties my obligations now my view is
Monas prior a duties before rights
and but 35 years ago I had the privilege
to to be taught by a philosophy by a man
called John Rawls and in his seminal
work a theory of justice he set out a
vision of justice as fairness that was
practical and political rather than
absolute and metaphysical and any
conception of political justice he
thought had to rise to the challenge of
pluralism and allow for a variety of
sometimes conflicting ideas of what is
good and right and that they had to be
able to be affirmed in a democratic
society so in the sixty seconds I've got
remaining to me I simply want to say
that we are currently I think locked in
a struggle between those who see their
identities as rooted in place and class
and a particular culture and those who
see their identities as fluid and global
and culturally open like the heavens
look I think our politics no longer
exists in that post-war consensus around
a welfare state and certainly not in a
society of a shared belief in God or a
shared belief in loyalty to the crown
and I don't hanker after those days but
I recognize that they provided a glue
which bound people together and in order
to achieve social stability politics has
to enable individual citizens to come
together in shared public institutions
individual citizens each who may have a
different conception of what it is to
live a good life yet when they come to
participate in those public institutions
now they don't find their sense of
self-worth affirmed on the contrary they
often find their beliefs reduced and
their identity rejected and whether
we're talking about creationist parents
not wanting their children taught about
evolution or anti-abortionists attacking
ters in the health service or just
elderly couples living in a street where
the language spoken is no longer their
own in our society we have not yet
developed a civic discourse that is able
to rise to the challenge of pluralism
and I think that that goes to the heart
of the brexit dilemma if each of us
engages with our fellow citizens first
by insisting upon our rights what we
believe is owed to us then I suspect we
never will develop that discourse if on
the other hand we start with our own
obligations to our fellow citizens if we
go back to the primary school motto duty
before rights then perhaps we will and
that that is the sort of future for
Britain that I want to see for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you